let's systematically name some
carboxylic acid so let's say at a
molecule that looked like that looked
like this clearly a carboxylic acid we
have a carboxyl group right over right
over here now to name it systematically
we do it just the way we've named our
simple alkanes when we first learned how
to name any organic molecule you look
for the longest carbon chain and the
longest carbon chain is one two three
four carbons so our prefix will be Butte
so it's butan and instead of calling it
butane instead of writing this II hear
we know this is a carboxylic acid it has
this carboxyl group so we call it
butanoic butanoic acid and now you might
wonder hey don't we have to specify
where the carboxyl where the carboxyl
group is and if you look at how
carboxylic acids are arranged you can
tell the carboxyl group is always going
to be at one end of a carbon chain so
you don't have to specify in fact you
always want to start numbering at
wherever the carboxyl wherever the
carboxyl carbon is so if you had to
number these this would be the one
carbon the 2 the 3 and the 4 so you
don't have to specify a number for the
carboxyl group let's do another one
let's say let's say we had something
that looked like this let's say we had
something that looked let me put let me
put another carbon on there just like
that and let's say that there's a methyl
group let's say that there's a methyl
group right over there now clearly a
carboxylic acid but to name it
systematically we just want to find the
longest carbon chain so we have 1 2 3 4
5 6 carbons so our prefix will be hex
so it's hex and it is hex and it's
clearly not just a hexane it's a
hexanoic acid it has this carboxyl group
right here this is hexanoic hexanoic
acid and we're not done because we still
have this methyl carbon right over here
and it is on the we always want to start
numbering at this carbonyl carbon 1 2
three four five six it is at the number
three carbon so this is three methyl
three three methyl hexanoic acid let's
do one more let's say we had a molecule
a molecule that looked like this let's
see that's one two three four five six
seven carbons and then we have our
carboxyl group just like that and let's
say that we had a double bond right over
there what would we call this
well once again look for the longest
carbon chain longest carbon chain we
have one two three four five six seven
carbons so the prefix is hepped prefixes
hep so it's HEPT and we won't just and
actually let me be careful this isn't an
alkane this has a double bond right here
this has a double bond right over here
so it's hep teen if this was just an
alkene we would just call it hep teen
but we're not going to put this last a
here because this is a the carboxylic
acid and to specify where that double
bond is we need to start numbering every
number start numbering at the carbonyl
carbon 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 so you could either
name this 3 hep diene and we'll I
haven't finished it yet I haven't put
this final over here or you could name
it HEPT HEPT 3 een just like that this
is the more typical one that you would
see because it tells you okay this is we
have a double bond and it's on it starts
at the number 3 carbon goes from the 3
to the 4 carbon but this isn't just a
regular alkene this is a carboxylic acid
so instead of writing that final EE here
for an alkene we write it as we have a
carboxyl group right here so this is 3
hep D Noack hep D Noack acid and we are
done and actually if you wanted to get
really fancy on this one right over here
you could see that these two carbons
that are on the double bond so this
carbon and this carbon it's kind of a
range like this if you view this as let
me draw it like this they both have
other hydrogen's up
there that we didn't draw they're
implicitly there but if you wanted to
rewrite or redraw this molecule you
could draw it like this you have two
carbons just like this
this one has a hydrogen popping up like
that that one has a hydrogen popping
down like that and then this carbon this
carbon over here has this big functional
group over here we'll call that R so
this is R and then this one over here
I'll do it in green has this other
functional group has these three carbons
we could call that our prime these three
carbons are our prime and if you look at
it this way you like hey look the
functional groups are on opposite sides
of the double bond they're away from
each other so if you wanted to you could
also call this trans trans we could even
write an italic trans 3 hep D Noack acid
and this will specify that these guys
are on opposite ends but this is only if
you're assuming that I kind of drew it
in the actual three-dimensional
configuration in some way anyway
hopefully you found that useful